So David was working, making his living as a maid, basically, cleaning apartments, when the whole Christmas thing hit him. And it hit him by accident. It was all completely by accident that he became a Christmas writer. He never planned it. He basically wrote a story that was excerpts from his diaries when he was working as an elf at Macy's Department Store during the Christmas season.
大卫当时正在工作，靠当女佣谋生，基本上就是清理公寓，这时整个圣诞节的事情突然降临在他身上。这完全是一场意外。他成为一名圣诞作家完全是纯属巧合。他从没计划过。他写的故事基本上就是他还在梅西百货担任圣诞精灵时的日记摘录。
I wear green velvet knickers, a forest green velvet smock, and a perky little hat decorated with spangles. This is my work uniform.
我穿着绿色天鹅绒灯笼裤，一件森林绿色的天鹅绒罩衫，还有一顶装饰着亮片的俏皮小帽子。这就是我的工作制服。
This story was this very popular story. Book deals, movie offers, all sorts of other work poured in, and then after that, every year somebody would ask him to write another Christmas story-- NPR, The New Yorker magazine, the New York Times Op-Ed page. It was a strange assignment to get year after year. And something about it just gave him this strange feeling. He just did not want to be that Christmas guy, the elf.
这个故事非常受欢迎。图书交易、电影邀约、各种各样的其他工作纷至沓来，从那以后，每年都有人请他写另一篇圣诞故事——美国国家公共电台、《纽约客》杂志、《纽约时报》评论版。年复一年接到这样的任务真是件奇怪的事。不知为何，这让他有一种奇怪的感觉。他只是不想成为那个“圣诞男”、那个精灵。
So he proceeded to write a series of stories that are so dark, and so full of greed and pettiness and spite, that sometimes it seems like David is on a single-handed mission to try to destroy Christmas. But that is an accident too, because the thing about David Sedaris in real life, really, he loves Christmas. I talked to his sister, Tiffany, about it this week from Boston.
于是他开始写一系列非常黑暗、充满贪婪、琐碎和怨恨的故事，有时看起来大卫好像是在单枪匹马地试图摧毁圣诞节。但这也是一场意外，因为现实生活中的大卫·塞达里斯其实很喜欢圣诞节。本周我在波士顿采访了他的妹妹蒂芙尼。
It's a very serious thing to him. He'll call you in June and say, I'm all done with my Christmas shopping. And I'm like, is there some kind of time change between here and New York that I don't know anything about? Because it's, like, 110 here.
这对他是件非常严肃的事情。他会在六月打电话给你说，我的圣诞购物都买完了。我就问，我们和纽约之间有什么我不了解的时差吗？因为这里当时有110度（华氏）。
His sister, Amy, confirms this.
他的妹妹艾米证实了这一点。
Man, he is. He gets dressed up. He stays up really late on Christmas Eve, on the tree, just staring at the tree, and shaking presents so hard that they would break, until you would hear some kind of rattling going on.
天哪，他确实是这样。他会精心打扮。他在平安夜熬到很晚，对着圣诞树，只是盯着树看，摇晃礼物，直到它们发出咯咯声，摇晃得非常用力，以至于你会听到某种响声。
David's father, Lou.
大卫的父亲卢。
My money didn't mean anything. To him, it was important that everybody spent as much money, I guess, as he spent on them.
我的钱没有任何意义。对他来说，重要的是每个人都花了和他花在他们身上一样多的钱，我想。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
I keep a list every year of what I gave everybody and how much it cost, and what they gave me and how much I think that cost.
我每年都保留一份清单，记录我给了谁什么，花了多少钱，以及他们给了我什么，我估计价值多少。
Incredibly, David did confirm his father's story.
令人难以置信的是，大卫确实证实了他父亲的故事。
Because a lot of people, you can ask in February, what did you get for Christmas? And they won't even remember. So this allows me to remember. It also allows me to think, to look over that list and maybe give it a little thought before the next Christmas.
因为很多人，你二月份问他们圣诞节收到了什么？他们甚至都不记得了。所以这让我能够记住。它也让我可以思考，回顾那份清单，在下一个圣诞节前好好考虑一下。
Like last Christmas, Hugh gave me a pillow. A pillow.
比如去年圣诞节，休送了我一个枕头。一个枕头。
This is your boyfriend, Hugh.
这是你的男朋友，休。
Yeah, and he disguised it, he put it in a big box, he made it heavy. I had no idea what it was. But I didn't think it was a pillow. A pillow's one of those things you buy together. He gave me a comforter also, as if I slept on the couch, and this was my comforter, and he could never use it.
是的，他伪装了它，把它放在一个大盒子里，做得沉甸甸的。我根本不知道是什么。但我没想到是枕头。枕头是那种你们一起买的东西。他还给了我一条被子，好像我睡在沙发上，这是我的被子，而他永远用不到。
So you noted that in the list.
所以你把那项记在清单上了。
Yes, I noted it.
是的，我记下了。
And what's it going to mean this year for Christmas, for Hugh?
那这对休来说，今年的圣诞节意味着什么？
Well, it should've meant trouble for him. But actually, I got him something-- he's going to have to be nice to me for the next 12 years. Another good thing about it, is you just know how much it cost. Usually, if I give a present that's over a certain amount, I leave the price tag on and say, that's in case you wanted to exchange it. Or sometimes I'll add zeros or ones to the price tag that already exists. If you're going to spend that much money, people to know.
嗯，本该意味着他的麻烦了。但实际上，我给他准备了一份礼物——他未来12年都得对我好点。它的另一个好处是，你清楚地知道它花了多少钱。通常，如果我送的礼物超过一定金额，我会保留价格标签，并说，那是为了方便你更换。有时我甚至会在原有的价格标签上多加几个零或一。如果你要花那么多钱，就得让人知道。
I should probably explain what's going on here to anybody listening to the radio right now. We are broadcasting today from a huge auditorium in Los Angeles. And I'm on stage.
我想我应该向现在正在收听广播的各位解释一下这里发生了什么。我们今天是在洛杉矶的一个巨大礼堂进行广播。我正在舞台上。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Thank you. I'm on stage. There's a Christmas tree, and there's  a toy train set. And there's lots of poinsettias, and stockings are hung by the chimney with care. And besides that, there are no lights on at all. And the audience here in the theater, I think, is beginning to wonder, is the whole show going to be this way? People, I think, are saying, this is a little too much like the radio show. We paid 21 bucks, So let's bring the lights up.
谢谢。我正在舞台上。这里有一棵圣诞树，还有一套玩具火车。还有很多一品红，长筒袜被小心地挂在壁炉旁。除此之外，根本没有开灯。我想这里的观众开始纳闷了，整个节目都要这样吗？我想人们在说，这太像广播节目了。我们花了21美元，所以把灯打开吧。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program--
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目——
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Today on our program, A Very Special David Sedaris Christmas. Thanks to public radio station KCRW in Santa Monica, we are here today in the thrillingly large Wadsworth Theatre in Los Angeles. On our program today, stories from David Sedaris' new book of Christmas stories, Holidays on Ice , read by David, Julia Sweeney, and Matt Malloy. Act One of our program, Front Row Center with Thaddeus Bristol. A high-powered drama critic deploys his skills to critique the Christmas pageants at local elementary schools.
今天我们的节目是“非常特别的大卫·塞达里斯圣诞节”。感谢位于圣莫尼卡的公共广播电台KCRW，我们今天来到洛杉矶令人激动的巨大沃兹沃斯剧院。在今天的节目中，将朗读大卫·塞达里斯的新书《冰上假日》中的故事，由大卫、茱莉亚·斯威尼和马特·马洛伊朗读。节目第一幕，《萨迪斯·布里斯托的前排中心》。一位权势显赫的戏剧评论家运用他的技能对当地小学的圣诞演出进行评论。
Act Two, Seasons Greetings to Our Friends and Family! The annual holiday letter from one typical American family.
第二幕，《致朋友和家人的节日问候！》。一个典型美国家庭的年度节日家书。
Act Three, Based on a True Story. What happens when you mix a TV producer, a small town church, a miracle, a side-by-side refrigerator, and $1,200 cash. Stay with us.
第三幕，《根据真实故事改编》。当你把电视制片人、小镇教堂、奇迹、并排式冰箱和1200美元现金混在一起时会发生什么。敬请关注。
Act One, Front Row Center with Thaddeus Bristol. Our first reader is David Sedaris.
第一幕，《萨迪斯·布里斯托的前排中心》。我们的第一位朗读者是大卫·塞达里斯。
Front Row Center with Thaddeus Bristol. Trite Christmas-- Scottsfield's young hams offer the blandest of holiday fare.
《萨迪斯·布里斯托的前排中心》。平庸的圣诞——斯科茨菲尔德的年轻演员们献上最乏味的节日大餐。
The approach of Christmas signifies three things-- bad movies, unforgivable television, and even worse theater. I'm talking bone-crushing theater, the type our ancient ancestors used to oppress their enemies before the invention of the stretching rack. We're talking torture on a par with the Scottsfield Dinner Theater's 1994 revival of Come Blow Your Horn , a production that violated every tenet of the Human Rights Accord.
圣诞节的临近预示着三件事——烂电影、不可原谅的电视节目，甚至更糟糕的戏剧。我说的是那种令人崩溃的戏剧，是我们古老的祖先在发明拉伸架之前用来压迫敌人的那种。我们谈论的是一种堪比斯科茨菲尔德晚餐剧院1994年复排的《Come Blow Your Horn》的酷刑，那部作品违反了《人权公约》的每一条原则。
To those of you who enjoy the comfort of a nice set of thumbscrews, allow me to recommend any of the crucified holiday plays and pageants currently eliciting screams of mercy from within the confines of our local elementary and middle schools. I will, no doubt, be taken to task for criticizing the work of children. But as any pathologist will agree, if there's a cancer, it's best to treat it as soon as possible.
对于那些喜欢酷刑折磨的人，我推荐任何一部目前正从我们当地小学和中学里引发阵阵求救尖叫的十字架节日剧和演出。我无疑会因为批评孩子们的作品而受到指责。但正如任何病理学家都会同意的那样，如果有了癌症，最好尽快治疗。
If you happen to stand over four feet tall, the agony awaiting you at Sacred Heart Elementary began the moment you took your seat. These were mean little chairs, corralled into a theater haunted by the lingering stench of industrial-strength lasagna. My question is not why they chose to stage the production in a poorly-disguised cafeteria but why they chose to stage it at all. The story of the first Christmas is an overrated clunker of a holiday pageant, best left to those looking to cure their chronic insomnia.
如果你身高超过四英尺，在圣心小学等待你的苦难从你坐下的那一刻就开始了。这些是狭窄的小椅子，被围在一个弥漫着工业级千层面臭味的剧院里。我的问题不是他们为什么选择在一个伪装得很差的食堂里上演，而是他们为什么要上演。第一个圣诞节的故事是一个被高估的节日演出废品，最好留给那些试图治疗慢性失眠症的人。
Although the program listed no director, the apathetic staging suggested the limp, partially-paralyzed hand of Sister Mary Elizabeth Bronson, who should've been excommunicated after last season's disasterous Thanksgiving program. Here again, the first through third-grade actors graced the stage with an enthusiasm most children reserve for a smallpox vaccination. One could hardly blame them for their lack of vitality, as the stingy, uninspired script consists not of springy dialogue but rather of a deadening series of pronouncements.
虽然节目单上没有写导演，但冷漠的舞台设计暗示了玛丽·伊丽莎白·布朗森修女那只无力、近乎瘫痪的手，她在上个赛季灾难性的感恩节节目后就应该被逐出教会。在这里，一到三年级的演员们再次带着孩子们通常只在接种天花疫苗时才会表现出的那种热情登上了舞台。人们几乎不能责怪他们缺乏活力，因为吝啬、毫无灵感的剧本并没有充满活力的对话，而是一连串令人麻木的声明。
Mary to Joseph, I am tired. Joseph to Mary, we will rest here for the night. There's no fire, no give and take. And the audience soon grows weary of this passionless relationship.
玛丽对约瑟夫说，我累了。约瑟夫对玛丽说，我们今晚就在这里休息。没有火，没有交流。观众很快就会对这种毫无激情的关系感到厌倦。
In the role of Mary, six-year-old Shannon Burke just barely manages to pass herself off as a virgin. A cloying, preening stage presence, her performance seemed based on nothing but an annoying proclivity towards lifting her skirt and, on rare occasion, opening her eyes.
在扮演玛丽的角色中，六岁的香农·伯克勉强让人觉得她是个处女。一种令人厌烦、搔首弄姿的舞台表现，她的表演似乎完全基于一种提起裙子，偶尔睁开眼睛的烦人倾向。
As Joseph, second-grade student Douglas Trazzare needed to be reminded that although his character did not technically impregnate the virgin mother, he should behave as though he were capable of doing so. Thrown into the mix were a handful of inattentive shepherds and a trio of gift-bearing seven-year-olds who could probably give The Three Stooges a run for their money.
作为约瑟夫，二年级学生道格拉斯·特拉扎雷需要被提醒，尽管他的角色从技术上讲并没有让童贞女怀孕，但他应该表现得好像他有能力这样做一样。混合在一起的还有几个心不在焉的牧羊人，以及三个送礼物的七岁孩子，他们或许可以让“三个臭皮匠”自叹不如。
As for the lighting, Sacred Heart Elementary chose to rely on nothing more than the flashbulbs ignited by the obnoxious stage mothers and fathers who had created those zombies, staggering back and forth across the linoleum-floored dining hall. Pointing to the oversized crate that served as a manger, one particularly insufficient wise man proclaimed, a child is bored. Yes, well, so is this adult.
至于灯光，圣心小学选择仅仅依赖那些创造了这些僵尸的讨厌的舞台父母们点燃的闪光灯，他们在油毡地板的餐厅里走来走去。指着那个充当马槽的超大板条箱，一个特别不称职的智者宣称，一个孩子很无聊。是的，好吧，这个大人也很无聊。
Once again, the sadists at the Jane Snow-Hernandez Middle School have taken up their burning pokers in an attempt to prod A Christmas Carol into some form of submission. I might have overlooked the shoddy production values and dry, leaden pacing, but these are sixth graders we're talking about, and they ought to know better. There's really no point in adapting this Dickensian stinker, unless you're capable of looking beyond the novel's dime-store morality and getting to what little theatrical meat the story has to offer. The point is to eviscerate the gooey center, but here, it's served up as the entree. And a foul pudding it is.
再一次，简·斯诺-埃尔南德斯中学的施虐者们拿起了他们的烧火棍，试图强迫《圣诞颂歌》以某种形式屈服。我本可以忽略那些拙劣的制作水准和干巴巴、沉重的节奏，但我们谈论的是六年级的学生，他们应该表现得更好。真的没有必要改编这部狄更斯式的烂片，除非你有能力透过小说那廉价的道德观，看到这个故事所能提供的仅有的一点戏剧性血肉。重点是去除那些黏糊糊的核心，但在这里，它被当作主菜端上来了。这真是一份糟糕的布丁。
Most of the blame goes to the director, 11-year-old Becky Michaels, who seems to have picked up her staging secrets from the school's crossing guard. She tends to clump her actors, moving them only in groups of five or more. A strong proponent of trendy, racially-mixed casting, Michaels gives us a black Tiny Tim, leaving the audience to wonder, what, is this kid supposed to be adopted? It's a distracting move, wrongheaded and pointless.
大部分责任归咎于导演，11岁的贝基·迈克尔斯，她似乎从学校的过马路保安那里学到了舞台调度技巧。她倾向于把演员聚在一起，只让他们以五人或更多人的小组移动。作为时尚、种族混合选角的坚定支持者，迈克尔斯给我们提供了一个黑人小蒂姆，让观众纳闷，这个孩子是被收养的吗？这是一种令人分心的举动，方向错误且毫无意义。
The role was played by young Lamar Williams who, if nothing else, managed to sustain a decent limp. The program noted that he'd recently lost his right foot to diabetes, but was that reason enough to cast him? As Tiny Tim, the boy's spends his stage time essentially trawling for sympathy, stealing focus from even the brightly-lit exit sign.
这个角色由年轻的拉马尔·威廉姆斯扮演，如果说有什么优点的话，他确实保持了一个不错的瘸腿姿势。节目单提到他最近因糖尿病失去了右脚，但这就足以让他担任这个角色了吗？作为小蒂姆，这个男孩在舞台上的时间基本都在博取同情，从甚至连明亮的出口标志那里偷走注意力。
I was gagging from the smell of spray-painted sneakers, and if I see one more top hat made from an oatmeal canister, I swear to god, I'm going to pull out a gun. The problem with all of these shows stems partially from their maddening eagerness to please. With smiles stretched tight as bungee cords, these hopeless amateurs pranced and gamboled across our local stages, hiding behind their youth and begging-- practically demanding-- we forgive their egregious mistakes.
我因为喷漆运动鞋的味道而作呕，如果我再看到一个用燕麦罐做的礼帽，我发誓，我要掏枪了。所有这些节目的问题部分源于他们令人抓狂的取悦渴望。随着笑容像蹦极绳一样紧绷，这些无可救药的业余爱好者在我们的当地舞台上蹦蹦跳跳，躲在他们的年轻背后乞求——实际上是在要求——我们原谅他们明显的错误。
While billing themselves as holiday entertainment, none of these productions came close to capturing the true spirit of Christmas. This glaring irony seemed to escape the throngs of ticket holders who ate these undercooked turkeys right down to the bone. Here were audiences that chuckled at every technical snafu, and applauded riotously each time a new character wandered out onto the stage. With the close of every curtain, they leapt to their feet in one ovation after another, leaving me wedged into my doll-sized chair and wondering, is it just them, or am I missing something?
虽然标榜为节日娱乐，但这些作品中没有一部能捕捉到圣诞节的真正精神。这种明显的讽刺似乎逃过了那些把这些未煮熟的火鸡吃得连骨头都不剩的观众的眼睛。这里的观众对每一次技术失误都嗤之以鼻，每当一个新角色蹒跚走上舞台时，他们都报以狂热的掌声。每一次幕布落下，他们都会一次又一次地跳起来欢呼，这让我被挤在自己玩偶大小的椅子里，心想，是他们的问题，还是我错过了什么？
David Sedaris.
大卫·塞达里斯。
Act Two, Season's Greetings to Our Friends and Family! Well, our reader for this next story is Julia Sweeney, who completely rocks. Julia is a writer and actress. She was a cast member on Saturday Night Live for four years. Her sad and comic memoir of life with cancer, God Said, "Ha!", ran on Broadway this year, and a film of that one-woman show is going to be released next year in theaters. Please welcome her.
第二幕，《致朋友和家人的节日问候！》。好吧，我们下一个故事的朗读者是茱莉亚·斯威尼，她棒极了。茱莉亚是一位作家和演员。她曾在《周六夜现场》担任四年演员。她关于癌症生活的悲剧与喜剧回忆录《上帝说，“哈！”》今年在百老汇上演，那部独角戏的电影明年将在影院上映。请欢迎她。
Season's greetings to our friends and family. Many of you, our friends and family, are probably taken aback by this, our annual holiday newsletter. You've read of our recent tragedy in the newspapers and were, no doubt, thinking that with all of their sudden legal woes and hassles, the Dunbar clan might be just sticking their heads in the sand and avoiding this upcoming holiday season altogether. Well, think again.
致朋友和家人的节日问候。你们中的许多朋友和家人可能对我们这份年度节日通讯感到吃惊。你们在报纸上读到了我们最近的悲剧，毫无疑问会想，面对所有突然的法律困境和麻烦，邓巴家族可能会像把头埋在沙子里一样，完全避开即将到来的节日。嗯，再想想吧。
Our tree is standing tall in the living room. The stockings are hung, and we are eagerly awaiting the arrival of a certain portly gentleman who goes by the name of St. Nick. Our trusty PC printed out our wish lists weeks ago, and now we're cranking it up again to wish you and yours the merriest of Christmas seasons from the entire Dunbar family, Clifford, Jocelyn, Kevin, Jacki, Kyle, and Khe Sahn.
我们的圣诞树在客厅里高高伫立。长筒袜已经挂好，我们正急切地等待着那位名叫圣尼克的胖绅士到来。我们可靠的电脑几周前就打印出了我们的愿望清单，现在我们又要全力以赴，祝愿你们和你们的家人度过一个最快乐的圣诞节，来自邓巴家族全体成员，克利福德、乔斯林、凯文、杰基、凯尔和溪山。
Some of you are probably reading this and scratching your heads over the name Khe Sahn. That certainly doesn't fit with the rest of the family names, you're saying to yourself. What, did those crazy Dunbars get themselves a Siamese cat? Well, you're close. To those of you live in a cave and haven't heard the news, allow us to introduce Khe Sahn Dunbar who, at the age of 22, happens to be the newest member of our family. Surprised? Join the club.
你们中有些人读到这里可能对“溪山”这个名字感到困惑。你们会对自己说，那肯定不符合家族其他成员的名字。怎么，那些疯狂的邓巴一家弄了一只暹罗猫吗？嗯，你猜对了。对于那些住在洞穴里没听过这个消息的人，请允许我们介绍溪山·邓巴，她今年22岁，恰好是我们家的新成员。惊讶吗？加入我们吧。
It appears that Clifford-- husband of yours truly and father to our three natural children-- accidentally planted the seeds for Khe Sahn 22 years ago during his stint in, where else, Vietnam. Clifford Dunbar, 22 years ago, a young man in a war-torn country, made a mistake, a terrible, heinous mistake. A stupid, thoughtless, permanent mistake with dreadful, haunting consequences.
看来克利福德——我那亲爱的丈夫，我们三个亲生孩子的父亲——22年前在他驻扎在——还能在哪呢——越南时意外播下了溪山的种子。克利福德·邓巴，22年前，一个在战乱国家的年轻人，犯了一个错误，一个可怕、令人发指的错误。一个愚蠢、轻率、持久的错误，带来了可怕的、挥之不去的后果。
But who are you-- who are any of us-- to judge him for it, especially now with Christmas at our heels. Who are we to judge? Khe Sahn arrived at our door on, as fate would have it, Halloween. I recall mistaking her for a trick-or-treater. She wore, I remember, a skirt the size of a beer cozy, a short, furry jacket, and on her face, enough rouge, eye shadow and lipstick to paint our entire house inside and out. She's a very small person, and I mistook her for a child, a child masquerading as a prostitute.
但是谁——我们中的谁——又有权评判他呢，特别是在圣诞节临近的时候。我们有什么资格评判？命运使然，溪山在万圣节来到了我们的门口。我记得误以为她是来讨糖的孩子。我记得她穿着一条啤酒保温套大小的裙子，一件短小的毛皮外套，脸上涂了足够的胭脂、眼影和口红，足以把我们整栋房子内外都涂一遍。她是个非常矮小的人，我把她误认为是个孩子，一个伪装成妓女的孩子。
I handed her a fistful of chocolate nougats, hoping that, like the other children, she would quickly move on to the next house. But Khe Sahn was no trick-or-treater. It is frightening that after all this time, a full-grown bastard-- and I use that word technically-- can cross the seas and make herself comfortable in my home, all with the blessing of our government. 22 years ago, Uncle Sam couldn't stand the Vietnamese, and now he's dressing them like prostitutes and moving them into our houses. Out of nowhere, this landmine knocks upon our door, and we are expected to recognize her as our child.
我给了她一把巧克力牛轧糖，希望像其他孩子一样，她会很快去下一家。但溪山不是讨糖的孩子。令人恐惧的是，经过这么长时间，一个成年混蛋——我是在技术意义上使用这个词——竟然能跨越重洋，并在我国政府的祝福下在我家安顿下来。22年前，山姆大叔还不能忍受越南人，现在他却把他们打扮成妓女，搬进我们的房子里。莫名其妙地，这颗地雷敲响了我们的门，而我们却被期望承认她是我们的孩子。
But Khe Sahn hasn't got the ambition God gave a sparrow. She arrived in this house six weeks ago speaking only the words, "daddy," "shiny," and "five dollar now." Quite a vocabulary. While an industrious person might buckle down and seriously study the language of her newly adopted country, Khe Sahn appeared to be in no hurry whatsoever. When asked a simple question-- such as, why don't you go back to where you came from?-- she would touch my hand and launch into a spasm of Vietnamese drivel, as if I were an outsider, as if I were expected to learn her language.
但溪山连麻雀那点野心都没有。她六周前来到这个家，只会说“爸爸”、“闪亮”和“现在五美元”这些词。真是好词汇量。虽然一个勤奋的人可能会埋头苦干，认真学习她新收养国家的语言，但溪山似乎一点也不着急。当被问到一个简单的问题——比如，为什么你不回到你来的地方去？——她会摸摸我的手，开始喷出一连串的越南语废话，好像我是个局外人，好像我应该学习她的语言一样。
Clifford suggested that we hire an English tutor, but I am not in the habit of throwing my money away. And that, my friends, is what it would have amounted to. Why not hire an expensive private tutor to teach the squirrels to speak in French? It would be no more ridiculous than teaching Khe Sahn English. A person has to want to learn. I know that. Apparently, back in Ho Chi Minh City, her majesty was treated like a queen and sees no reason to change her ways.
克利福德建议我们聘请一位英语家教，但我没有浪费钱的习惯。而那，我的朋友们，就是它会变成的样子。为什么不聘请昂贵的私人教师教松鼠说法语呢？这并不比教溪山英语更荒谬。一个人必须想学。我知道这一点。显然，在胡志明市，女王陛下被当作女王对待，看不到改变自己方式的理由。
Her highness rises around noon, wolfs down a fish or two-- all she eats is fish and chicken breasts-- and settles herself before the make up mirror, waiting for her father to return home from work. At the sound of his car in the driveway, she perks up and races to the door like a spaniel, panting and wagging her tail to beat the band. Suddenly, she is eager to please and attempt conversation. Well, I don't know how they behave in Vietnam, but in the United States, it is not customary for a half-dressed daughter to offer her father a five-dollar massage.
她的殿下大约中午起床，狼吞虎咽地吃下一两条鱼——她只吃鱼和鸡胸肉——然后坐在化妆镜前，等着她父亲下班回来。听到他在车道上的车声，她振作起来，像小西班牙猎狗一样跑向门口，喘着气，摇着尾巴。突然间，她渴望取悦并尝试交谈。嗯，我不知道他们在越南表现如何，但在美国，一个衣着暴露的女儿给父亲提供五美元的按摩是不合常理的。
After having spent an exhausting day attempting to communicate a list of simple chores, I would stand in amazement of Khe Sahn's sudden grasp of English when faced with my husband. "Daddy happy five-dollar shiny now, OK? You big feet friendly with ABC Khe Sahn you Big Bird daddy Grover." Apparently, she'd picked up a few words while watching Sesame Street.
在经历了试图沟通一长串简单家务的劳累一天后，我惊讶于溪山在面对我丈夫时突然掌握的英语。“爸爸高兴五美元闪亮，好吗？你大脚对ABC溪山你大鸟爸爸格罗弗。”显然，她在看《芝麻街》时学到了几个词。
It was a taxing experience for us all, especially our daughter Jackelyn, whose nerves have been, well, permanently jangled by drugs. You may have heard something about this and, no doubt, understand that it wasn't our fault. We had, of course, warned Jackelyn against marrying Timothy Speaks. We warned, we threatened, cautioned, advised, what have you, but it did no good, as a young girl with all the evidence before her only sees what she wants to see. The marriage was bad enough, but the news of her pregnancy struck her father and me with the force of a hurricane.
这对我们大家来说是一次吃力的经历，尤其是我们的女儿杰克琳，她的神经已经被，嗯，药物彻底搞乱了。你们可能听说过这件事，毫无疑问也明白，这不是我们的错。我们当然警告过杰克琳不要嫁给蒂莫西·斯皮克斯。我们警告过，威胁过，提醒过，劝告过，随便什么都试过，但都没用，因为一个年轻女孩在所有证据面前只看她想看到的。婚姻已经够糟糕了，但她怀孕的消息像飓风一样击中了她父亲和我。
Timothy Speaks, the father of our grandchild? How could it be? Timothy Speaks, who has so many pierced holes in his ears you could have torn the lobe right off, effortlessly ripped it loose the same way you might separate a stamp from a sheet. We, of course, saw it coming. Faced with the concrete responsibility of fatherhood, Timothy Speaks abandoned his sick wife and child. Suddenly. Gone. Poof.
蒂莫西·斯皮克斯，我们孙子的父亲？怎么可能？蒂莫西·斯皮克斯，他耳朵上有那么多穿孔，你本可以把耳垂撕下来，就像你把邮票从纸上撕下来一样轻松地把它扯掉。我们当然预见到了。面对为人父的实际责任，蒂莫西·斯皮克斯抛弃了他生病的妻子和孩子。突然间。不见了。砰。
Surprised? Well, we saw it coming. We have all read the studies and understand that a drug-addicted baby faces a difficult, uphill battle in terms of living a normal life. This child, having been given the legal name Satan Speaks, would, we felt, have a harder time than most. We were lucky enough to get Jacki into a fine treatment center on the condition that the child remain here with us until which time, if ever, she was able to assume responsibility for him.
惊讶吗？嗯，我们预见到了。我们都读过研究报告，了解吸毒成瘾的婴儿在过正常生活方面面临着艰难的、上坡的战斗。我们觉得，这个孩子，既然合法名字叫撒旦·斯皮克斯，比起大多数人来说会更加困难。我们很幸运地把杰基送进了一家很好的治疗中心，条件是孩子留在这里由我们照顾，直到她有能力承担起照顾他的责任为止。
The child arrived at our home on November 10, and shortly thereafter, following her initial withdrawal, Jacki granted us permission to address it as Don. Don, a nice, simple name. While I could not describe him as being a normal baby, taking care of young Don gave me a great deal of pleasure. Terribly insistent, prone to hideous rashes, a 24-hour, round-the-clock screamer, he was our grandchild, and we loved him. Knowing that he would physically grow into adulthood while maintaining the attention span of a common house fly did not in the least bit diminish our feelings for him.
孩子在11月10日来到我们家，不久之后，在戒断期结束后，杰基允许我们叫他唐。唐，一个好的、简单的名字。虽然我不能描述他是一个正常的婴儿，但照顾小唐给了我极大的乐趣。极其执着，容易长可怕的皮疹，一个24小时不停歇的尖叫者，他是我们的孙子，我们爱他。知道他身体会长大成人，同时保持着普通苍蝇的注意力，这丝毫没有减弱我们对他的感情。
Clifford would sometimes joke that Don was a crack baby because he woke us at the crack of dawn. I would then take the opportunity to mention the Khe Sahn was something of a crack baby herself, wandering around our house at all hours of the day and night wearing nothing but a pair of hot pants and a glorified sports bra. Clifford suggested that I buy her a few decent dresses. So I made her several outfits, sewed them with my own hands, two floor-length dresses, beautiful burlap dresses. But she [? didn't ?] wear them.
克利福德有时会开玩笑说唐是瘾君子婴儿，因为他在破晓时分就把我们叫醒。我当时就会借机提到溪山自己也是个瘾君子婴儿，整天整夜在屋里游荡，只穿着一条热裤和一件华丽的运动文胸。克利福德建议我给她买几件得体的裙子。所以我给她做了几套衣服，亲手缝制的，两条及地长的裙子，漂亮的粗麻布裙子。但她[？没穿？]。
When the winter winds began to blow, she took to draping herself in a bed blanket, huddling beside the fireplace. She carried on, following at Clifford's heels until Thanksgiving Day, when she was introduced to our son, Kevin, home for the holiday. After graduating Moody High with honors, Kevin is currently enrolled in his third year at Feeny State, majoring in chemical engineering. He's made the honor roll every semester, and there seems to be no stopping him. We love you, Kevin.
当冬风开始吹起时，她开始把自己裹在毯子里，缩在壁炉边。她继续这样，跟在克利福德身后，直到感恩节那天，她被介绍给了我们回家过节的儿子凯文。凯文以优异成绩从穆迪高中毕业，目前在菲尼州立大学就读第三年，主修化学工程。他每学期都进入优等生榜，似乎没有任何事情能阻挡他。我们爱你，凯文。
But one look at Kevin and it was "Clifford? Clifford Who?" as far as Khe Sahn was concerned. One look at our handsome son and the shivering victim dropped her blanket and showed her true colors. She ruined our holiday dinner with her giggling, coy games. She sat beside Kevin until, insisting she'd seen a spider in her chair, she moved onto his lap.
但只要看一眼凯文，对溪山来说，“克利福德？克利福德是谁？”。只要看一眼我们英俊的儿子，那个发抖的受害者就扔掉了毯子，露出了她的真面目。她用她那咯咯的笑声和轻佻的游戏毁了我们的节日晚餐。她坐在凯文身边，直到坚称自己在椅子上看到了一只蜘蛛，然后坐到了他的腿上。
"You new funky master jam party mix silly fresh spider five dollar Big Bird."
“你新的时髦大师果酱派对混合愚蠢新鲜蜘蛛五美元大鸟。”
Now, those of you who know Kevin understand that while he is an absolute whip at some things, he's terribly naive at others. Tall and good looking, easy with a smile and a kind word, Kevin has been the target of many a huntress. I could barely choke down my meal and found myself counting the minutes before Kevin, the greatest joy of our lives, called an end to the private English lesson he gave Khe Sahn in her bedroom, got into his car, and returned to Feeny State.
现在，了解凯文的人都知道，虽然他在某些方面非常聪明，但在其他方面却天真得可怕。高大帅气，容易微笑和说好话，凯文一直是许多女猎手的目标。我几乎吃不下饭，发现自己数着分钟，直到凯文——我们生命中最大的快乐——结束了他给溪山在卧室里的私人英语课，上了他的车，回到了菲尼州立大学。
He's not for you, I yelled at her. I have been criticized for yelling, told that it doesn't serve any real purpose when speaking to a foreigner, but at least it gets their attention. Both my son and my husband are off limits, as far as you're concerned. Do you understand? They are each related to you in one way or another, and that makes it wrong-- automatically wrong. Bad, bad, wrong. Wrong and bad together.
他不适合你，我朝她大喊。我因为大喊大叫而受到批评，被告知在跟外国人说话时这没什么实际作用，但至少这能引起他们的注意。就你而言，我的儿子和我的丈夫都是禁区。你明白吗？他们每个人都和你有着这样那样的亲戚关系，这使它是错误的——自动错误的。坏的，坏的，错误。错误和坏加在一起。
I gave up. Trying to explain moral principles to Khe Sahn was like reviewing a standard 1040 tax form with a house cat. She understands only what she chooses to understand. We were approaching Christmas, December 16, when I made the thoughtless mistake of asking her to watch the child while I ran some errands. It was nine days before Christmas, and as busy as I was, I hadn't bought a single gift. Santa, where are you?
我放弃了。向溪山解释道德原则就像和家猫复习标准1040税表一样。她只理解她选择理解的东西。我们要接近圣诞节了，12月16日，我犯了一个轻率的错误，让她在跑腿时照看孩子。离圣诞节还有九天，我太忙了，连一件礼物都没买。圣诞老人，你在哪里？
Watch the baby, I said, as we stood over the crib and observed the wailing infant. I picked him up and rocked him gently as he struggled in my arms. Watch the baby.
照看婴儿，我说，当我们站在婴儿床边观察那个啼哭的婴儿时。我抱起他，轻轻摇晃着，他在我怀里挣扎。照看婴儿。
Watch baby, Khe Sahn responded, holding out her arms to accept him.
照看婴儿，溪山回应道，伸出双臂接过他。
Ugh, what a fool I was! Now, I can't account for every moment of my afternoon. Never did it occur to me that I would one day be called upon to do so, but that being the case, I will report what I remember. I can comfortably testify that on the afternoon of December 16, I visited the White Paw Shopping Center where I spent a brief amount of time in The Slack Heap, searching for a gift for Kyle. I stuck my head inside Turtleneck Crossing and search for candles at Wax and Wane. There are close to 100 shops at the White Paw Center, and you'll have to forgive me if I can't provide a detailed list of how long I spent in this or that store. I shopped until I grew wary of the time.
呃，我真是个傻瓜！现在，我无法交代我下午的每一刻。我从来没想过有一天会被要求这样做，但既然如此，我将报告我记得的事情。我可以肯定地作证，在12月16日下午，我去了白爪购物中心，在The Slack Heap度过了一小段时间，为凯尔寻找礼物。我把头伸进Turtleneck Crossing，在Wax and Wane寻找蜡烛。白爪中心有近100家商店，如果你无法提供我在哪家店待了多久的详细清单，请原谅我。我一直购物，直到对时间感到疲倦。
On the way home, I stopped at the Food Carnival and bought a few items. It was getting dark-- perhaps 4:30-- when I pulled into the driveway of our home on Tiffany Circle. I collected my packages from the car and entered my home where I was immediately struck by an eerie silence. This doesn't feel right to me, I remember saying to myself. It was intuition, a mother's intuition, that unexplainable language of the senses. Something is wrong, I said to myself. Something is terribly, terribly wrong.
回家的路上，我在食物狂欢节停了一下，买了些东西。天快黑了——大概4:30——当我驶入我们在蒂芙尼圈的家门时。我从车里收集了我的包裹，走进家门，立即被一种令人毛骨悚然的沉默所击中。这对我来说感觉不对，我记得对自己说。这是直觉，一种母亲的直觉，那种无法解释的感官语言。有什么不对劲，我对自己说。有什么非常、非常不对劲。
Before calling out for Khe Sahn or checking on the baby, I instinctively phoned the police. And then I stood there, stock still in the living room, staring at my shopping bags until they arrived 27 minutes later. At the sound of the squad car in the driveway, Khe Sahn made an entrance, parading down the stairs in a black lace half-slip and a choker made from the cuff of Kevin's old choir robe.
在叫喊溪山或检查婴儿之前，我本能地给警察打了电话。然后我就站在客厅里，一动不动，盯着我的购物袋，直到27分钟后他们到达。听到车道上的警车声，溪山现身了，她穿着黑色蕾丝半衬裙，脖子上戴着一条用凯文旧唱诗班长袍袖口做的颈圈，从楼梯上游行而下。
Where is the baby? I asked her. Where is Don? We combed the entire house, the officers and I, before finally finding the helpless baby in the laundry room, warm, but lifeless in the dryer. The autopsy later revealed that Don had also been subjected to a wash cycle-- hot wash, cold rinse. He died long before the spin cycle, which I suppose is the only blessing to be had in this entire, ugly episode. The shock and horror that followed Don's death are something I would rather not recount.
孩子在哪里？我问她。唐在哪里？我和警官们搜遍了整个房子，最后在洗衣房里发现了那个无助的婴儿，他很暖和，但已经没有生命迹象了，躺在烘干机里。验尸结果显示，唐也经历了一个洗涤周期——热洗，冷漂。他在脱水周期前很久就死了，我想这是整个丑陋插曲中唯一值得庆幸的一点。随后发生的关于唐死亡的震惊和恐惧，是我不愿复述的。
Calling our children to report the news, watching the baby's body, small as a loaf of bread, as it was zipped into the heavy plastic bag, this image has nothing to do with the merriment of Christmas, and I hope my mention of them will not dampen your spirits at this most special and glittery time of the year. The evening of December 16 was a very dark hour for the Dunbar family. At least with Khe Sahn in police custody, we could grieve privately, consoling ourselves with the belief that justice had been carried out.
给我们的孩子们打电话报告消息，看着那个像面包一样小的婴儿尸体被拉进沉重的塑料袋里，这一画面与圣诞节的欢庆无关，我希望提到它们不会在这一年中最特别和闪亮的时刻扫你们的兴。12月16日的夜晚对邓巴家族来说是一个非常黑暗的时刻。至少溪山被警方拘留，我们可以私下悲伤，安慰自己正义已经得到伸张。
The bitter tears were still wet upon our faces when the police returned to Tiffany Circle where they began their ruthless questioning of yours truly. Through the aid of interpreter, Khe Sahn had spent a sleepless night at police headquarters constructing a story of unspeakable lies and betrayal. While I'm not at liberty to discuss her exact testimony, allow me to voice my disappointment that anyone, let alone the police, would even think of taking Khe Sahn's word over my own. How could I have placed a helpless child in the machine? And even if I were cruel enough to do such a thing, when would I have found the time? I was out shopping.
我们的脸上还挂着苦涩的泪水，警察就回到了蒂芙尼圈，开始对本人进行无情的盘问。通过翻译的帮助，溪山在警察局度过了一个不眠之夜，构建了一个充满无法形容的谎言和背叛的故事。虽然我无权讨论她确切的证词，但请允许我表示失望，竟然有人，更不用说警察，会想到采信溪山的话而置我于不顾。我怎么可能把一个无助的孩子放进那台机器里？即使我真的残忍到那种地步，我哪来的时间？我当时正在外面购物。
You may have read that our so-called neighbor, Cherise Clarmont-Shea, reported that she witnessed me leaving my home at around 1:15 on the afternoon of December 16, and then, 20 minutes later, allegedly park my car on the far corner of Tiffany and Papa George and, in her words, creep through her backyard and in through my basement door.
你可能读到，我们所谓的邻居，切瑞丝·克莱蒙特-希，报告说她目击我在12月16日下午1:15左右离开家，然后，20分钟后，据称把车停在蒂芙尼和爸爸乔治的远角，用她的话说，从后院潜入并从地下室门进入我家。
Well, if the make up she applies is any indication of her vision, then I believe it is safe to say she can't see two inches in front of her, much less testify to the identity of someone she might think she's seen crossing her yard. She's on pills, Everybody knows that. She's desperate for attention, and I might pity her under different circumstances. Cherise Clarmont-Shea has no more sense than a hand puppet. She has three names.
嗯，如果她化的妆能说明她的视力的话，那么我相信可以肯定地说她连眼前两英寸都看不清，更不用说指证她可能以为看到越过她院子的人的身份了。她嗑药，所有人都知道。她渴望关注，在不同情况下我可能会同情她。切瑞丝·克莱蒙特-希还没一个手偶聪明。她有三个名字。
These charges, of course, are ridiculous, yet I must take them seriously, as my very life may be at stake. A hearing has been set for December 27, and knowing how disappointed you, our friends, might feel at being left out, I've included the time and address at the bottom of this letter. The hearing is an opportunity during which you might convey your belated Christmas spirit through deed and action. That heartfelt concern, that desire to stand by your friends and family is the very foundation upon which we celebrate the Christmas season, isn't it?
这些指控当然是荒谬的，但我必须认真对待，因为我的生命可能岌岌可危。听证会定于12月27日举行，知道你们——我们的朋友——被排除在外会感到多么失望，我在信的底部附上了时间和地址。听证会是一个机会，你们可以在期间通过行为和行动传达你们迟来的圣诞精神。那种真诚的关心，那种与朋友和家人站在一起的渴望，正是我们庆祝圣诞节的基础，不是吗？
While this year's Dunbar Christmas will be seasoned with loss and sadness, we plan to proceed as best we can toward that day of days, December 27, 1:45 PM at the White Paw County Courthouse, room 412. I'll be calling you to remind you of that information, and I look forward to discussing the festive bounty of your holiday season. Until that time, we wish the best to you and yours. Merry Christmas, the Dunbars.
虽然今年的邓巴圣诞节将伴随着损失和悲伤，但我们计划尽可能向前迈进，直到那一天——12月27日下午1:45，白爪县法院，412室。我会打电话给你们提醒你们这些信息，我期待着讨论你们节日里欢庆的收获。在那之前，祝你们和你们的家人一切顺利。圣诞快乐，邓巴一家。
Julia Sweeney. Coming up, Hollywood makes you a Christmas offer you cannot refuse. More David Sedaris Christmas stories. It's in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
茱莉亚·斯威尼。接下来，好莱坞会给你一个你无法拒绝的圣诞优惠。更多大卫·塞达里斯的圣诞故事。一分钟后回来，来自国际公共电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories from a variety of different writers and reporters and performers on that theme. But today, for the holidays, we bring you a set of Christmas stories by David Sedaris, read by David and others. We are broadcasting from the Wadsworth Theatre in Los Angeles.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们节目的大多数周都会选择一个主题，带给你各种各样的故事，来自各种各样的作家、记者和表演者。但今天，为了假期，我们为你带来一套大卫·塞达里斯的圣诞故事，由大卫和其他人朗读。我们是在洛杉矶的沃兹沃斯剧院进行广播。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Based on a True Story. Christmas stories are a lucrative business, and nobody knew that better than Charles Dickens. Charles Dickens actually-- this is a true story-- he actually wrote his classic story, A Christmas Carol , to get out of debt. And the book was this big hit. And this is 1843. And he proceeded to write another Christmas book every year from 1844 through 1848. And then every year between 1850 and 1867, he would write a Christmas something, somewhere in some magazine.
我们的节目进入了第三幕。第三幕，《根据真实故事改编》。圣诞故事是一门有利可图的生意，没有人比查尔斯·狄更斯更了解这一点。事实上，查尔斯·狄更斯——这是一个真实的故事——他实际上写了他的经典故事《圣诞颂歌》是为了还债。这本书一举成名。那是1843年。从1844年到1848年，他每年都写另一本圣诞书。然后从1850年到1867年，他每年都会在某本杂志上写一些圣诞节的东西。
Dickens, more than any other person, created. or at least popularized, our modern idea of Christmas. Before A Christmas Carol and his other Christmas stories, most people still thought of Christmas as a religious holiday. Dickens basically took the Christ out of Christmas. For Dickens, Christmas was basically just a big party, time to get together with family, drink punch, eat a huge meal, give gifts. John Jordan heads the Dickens Project at UC Santa Cruz.
狄更斯比任何其他人都创造了，或者至少普及了我们现代的圣诞节观念。在《圣诞颂歌》和其他圣诞故事之前，大多数人仍然认为圣诞节是一个宗教节日。狄更斯基本上把基督从圣诞节中拿走了。对于狄更斯来说，圣诞节基本上只是一场盛大的派对，是与家人团聚、喝潘趣酒、吃大餐、送礼物的时间。约翰·乔丹是加州大学圣克鲁兹分校狄更斯项目的负责人。
So the Cratchit family or Scrooge's nephew are models for how to hold a one-day family celebration with the goose or the turkey or whatever.
所以克拉奇一家或斯克罗吉的侄子是举行一天家庭庆典的模范，配上鹅、火鸡或其他什么。
Now if Dickens kind of made modern Christmas in his books, what would you say David Sedaris is doing in his new book of Christmas stories?
现在，如果狄更斯在他的书中创造了现代圣诞节，你会说大卫·塞达里斯在他的新圣诞故事书中在做什么？
Well, I think David Sedaris, he reminds me a lot of Scrooge, in a sense, in that he's saying "bah humbug" to the notion of Christmas. And the thing that's different about Sedaris is that Sedaris sustains that pose of disenchantment all the way through the stories, although I don't really believe that he's as dark as he pretends himself to be.
嗯，我想大卫·塞达里斯，在某种意义上他让我想起了斯克罗吉，因为他在对圣诞节的概念说“哼，废话”。而塞达里斯与众不同的是，塞达里斯在整个故事中都保持着这种幻灭的姿态，尽管我不认为他真的像他表现出的那样黑暗。
Oh, really? Why is that? What are you saying?
哦，真的吗？为什么？你在说什么？
Well, he's a satirist. And in order to be a satirist, you've got to have implicitly-- if not explicitly-- some standard of value against which you hold up all the things that you're making fun of.
嗯，他是一个讽刺作家。为了成为一名讽刺作家，你必须隐含地——如果不是明确地——拥有某种价值标准，用来衡量所有你在嘲弄的东西。
On of the producers of today's show, Julie Snyder, when we were researching this Dickens stuff, she summarized David's contribution to the Christmas genre this way, "Dickens took the Christ out of Christmas. David takes the fun out of Christmas."
今天节目的制片人之一，茱莉·斯奈德，当我们在研究这些狄更斯的东西时，她这样总结大卫对圣诞流派的贡献，“狄更斯把基督从圣诞中拿走了。大卫把圣诞的乐趣拿走了。”
I guess I could be accused of that. I don't know. I just can't help myself. I'm not trying to ruin-- I'm not trying to bring people down. I think I just tend to write Christmas stories that would make anyone else feel lucky.
我想我可能会被指责那样做。我不知道。我只是忍不住。我不是想毁掉——我不是想让人们感到沮丧。我想我只是倾向于写那些会让其他人觉得自己很幸运的圣诞故事。
Christmas was an important part of Dickens' livelihood through the end of his life. He was a wonderful reader, and he loved, actually, doing readings on stage, and toured. He toured. And he often read from A Christmas Carol . But sometimes, it bothered him. At some point, it became clear to him that he could not escape Christmas. He had done this thing that he could never get out of, that he could never turn his back on. He was permanently associated with it, and he was stuck.
圣诞节是狄更斯生命终结前重要的生计来源。他是一位出色的朗读者，他其实非常喜欢在舞台上朗读，并进行巡回演出。他巡演。他经常朗读《圣诞颂歌》。但有时，这会让他感到困扰。在某个时候，他清楚地意识到他无法逃脱圣诞节。他做了一件他永远无法摆脱的事情，他永远无法背弃的事情。他永久地与它联系在一起，他被困住了。
He wrote, in a letter to his daughter, Mamie, "It was as if I had murdered a Christmas a number of years ago, and its ghost perpetually haunted me."
他在给女儿玛米的信中写道：“就好像我在许多年前谋杀了一个圣诞节，它的鬼魂永远缠绕着我。”
That sounds like something I wrote in my diary.
听起来像是我在日记里写的东西。
What'd you say?
你说什么？
Well, it's the same way I feel about that Santaland story. It will haunt me forever. But I can't escape that. I'm an elf now. It'll be on my headstone.
嗯，这就是我对那个“桑塔乐园”故事的感觉。它将永远缠绕着我。但我无法逃避。我现在是个精灵了。它会出现在我的墓碑上。
And your feelings about that?
那你对此的感觉呢？
Well, the worst thing about being called an elf is that I really look like one. That's the worst thing. Like, if people were to call me a werewolf, I would think, well, that doesn't matter. I don't look anything like a werewolf. But today's elf is tomorrow's gnome. All it takes is a few more pounds and a little hair loss. I look like I should be living under a bridge with some goats.
嗯，被称为精灵最糟糕的事情是我真的长得像一个。那是件最糟糕的事。就像，如果人们叫我狼人，我会想，好吧，那没关系。我长得一点也不像狼人。但今天的精灵是明天的地精。只需要再胖几磅，掉点头发。我看起来应该住在桥下，和几只山羊在一起。
Well, our next story is the story of someone trying to cash in on Christmas by creating a big Christmas story. I heard about this next reader from David, actually. David and I were on the phone one day, and he had just seen the movie In the Company of Men . And he was urging me to see it and doing that by performing large sections of the movie for me over the phone. It's that kind of movie. And I saw it, and I loved it too. And I was really struck by one of the stars of the film, Matt Malloy, who gives, in the film, this great, squirmy, memorable performance. So it is with great pleasure that I welcome Matt Malloy here today on our stage.
嗯，我们的下一个故事是一个人试图通过创作一个伟大的圣诞故事来从圣诞节中获利的故事。其实我是从大卫那里听说这个朗读者的。有一天我和大卫在电话里聊天，他刚看了电影《在男人公司里》。他极力劝我去看，并且通过在电话里为我表演电影的大部分片段来做到这一点。就是那种电影。我看了，我也很喜欢。我真的很佩服电影的明星之一，马特·马洛伊，他在电影里给出了这个精彩、纠结、令人难忘的表演。所以，我非常荣幸今天欢迎马特·马洛伊来到我们的舞台。
Good morning, people, and Merry Christmas. Seeing as your minister, Brother Phil Becky, is running a bit late, I thought I'd take this opportunity to say a few words before he wheels himself back in to begin the traditional holiday service. So here I am, folks, filling in for Phil.
早上好，各位，圣诞快乐。既然你们的牧师，菲尔·贝基兄弟迟到了，我想趁这个机会说几句话，在他坐着轮椅回来开始传统的节日仪式之前。所以我就在这里，伙计们，填补菲尔的空缺。
"Who is this guy in his hand-tailored Savile Row suit?" you're asking yourselves. Those of you with little or no education are no doubt scratching your heads and thinking, "We ain't never seed him before. How you reckon he keeps his shoes so clean?"
“这个穿着手工缝制的萨维尔街西装的家伙是谁？”你们问自己。那些几乎没有受过教育的人无疑会抓着头想，“我们从来没见过他。你觉得他是怎么保持鞋子那么干净的？”
Now, friends, don't get me wrong. I'm not criticizing the way you talk. In fact, I kind of like it. As a people, you so-called hillbillies have made a remarkable contribution to the entertainment industry. And I, for one, thank you for that.
现在，朋友们，别误会我的意思。我不是在批评你们的说话方式。事实上，我有点喜欢。作为一个群体，你们所谓的乡下人对娱乐业做出了卓越的贡献。我个人感谢你们。
So who am I? For those of you who don't know me, my name is Jim Timothy. And as you probably gathered from my full set of God-given teeth, I'm not from around these parts. You see, folks, I work in the television industry. No, I'm not a repairman but what you call an executive producer. I guess you could call me the guy that makes it all happen.
那么我是谁？对于那些不知道我的人，我叫吉姆·蒂莫西。正如你们可能从我这口天生的满口好牙中推断出的那样，我不是这里的人。你们看，伙计们，我在电视行业工作。不，我不是修理工，而是你们所谓的执行制片人。我想你可以叫我那个让一切发生的人。
Due my highly-advanced sense of humor, I spent the first 10 years of my career developing situation comedies, or what we in the business like to refer to as "sitcoms." It was me who helped create such programs as Eight on a Raft, Darn Those Fleischmans, The Dating Cave , and Crackers and Company , a show you are probably familiar with, about a group of ignorant rednecks such as yourself. And I mean that in a good way.
由于我高度发达的幽默感，我职业生涯的前10年都在开发情景喜剧，或者我们业内喜欢称之为“情景喜剧”的东西。是我帮助创作了诸如《木筏上的八人》、《该死的弗莱什曼一家》、《约会洞穴》和《饼干公司》等节目，这是一个你们可能很熟悉的节目，关于一群像你们一样无知的乡巴佬。我指的是好的方面。
According to old man Webster, ignorant means lacking in knowledge and experience, which, let me tell you, can be something of a blessing. There's not a day that passes when I don't spend a few moments wondering if some of us aren't just a little too smart for our own good. You people with your simple, unremarkable lives know nothing about production schedules or the sky-high salaries demanded by certain so-called entertainers, who could give the Arabs themselves a few pointers on terrorism.
根据老韦伯斯特的说法，无知意味着缺乏知识和经验，这，我告诉你们，可能是一种福气。没有哪一天我不花点时间想，我们中间是不是有些人太聪明了，聪明反被聪明误。你们这些过着简单、平凡生活的人对制作进度或某些所谓艺人要求的、甚至能给阿拉伯人提供恐怖主义建议的超高薪水一无所知。
I, on the other hand, know nothing about scabies, so maybe we're even.
另一方面，我对疥疮一无所知，所以也许我们扯平了。
Due in large part to my extraordinary interpersonal relationship skills, I was eventually snatched up by a rival network and put in charge of dramatic programming. No, I'm not talking about the vapid soap operas people like you tend to enjoy. I'm referring to the hard-hitting, socially-relevant, and meaningful programs that reflect what's really going on in this country of ours.
在很大程度上，由于我非凡的人际关系处理能力，我最终被一家竞争对手的网络抢走，负责剧情节目。不，我说的不是你们这类人倾向于欣赏的那种空洞的肥皂剧。我说的是那些反思我们这个国家正在发生什么的、强有力的、具有社会意义且有意义的节目。
Without a laugh track or a standard 22-minute time frame, these are the shows that touch your heart rather than tickle your funny bone. These are programs in which good-looking people attempt to cope with life which, as many of you obviously know, isn't always as pretty as you'd like it to be. Sometimes these good-looking people are forced to visit poorly-decorated homes or even trailers.
没有笑声轨道或标准的22分钟时间限制，这些节目是触动你们心灵而不是逗乐你们笑骨的节目。这些节目中，好看的人试图应对生活，而正如你们许多人显然知道的那样，生活并不总是像你们希望的那样美好。有时这些好看的人被迫拜访装饰简陋的房子，甚至是拖车。
I'm talking about such award-winning programs as Cynthia Chin, Oriental Wet Nurse, Hal's Tumor, and White Like Me . I found my voice with situation comedies, proved myself with dramas, and felt it was time to move on to the ratings boosters we like to call the miniseries. Sometimes these programs are based upon novels written by many of your favorite authors, such as James Chutney and Jocelyn Hershey-Guest. I like to think we did a real justice to Olivia Hightop's Midnight's Cousin and E. Thomas Wallop's searing historical drama, The Business End of the Stick .
我谈论的是诸如《辛西娅·秦，东方奶妈》、《哈尔的肿瘤》和《像我一样的白人》等获奖节目。我在情景喜剧中找到了自己的声音，在剧中证明了自己，觉得是时候进入我们喜欢称之为迷你剧的收视率助推器了。有时这些节目基于许多你们喜爱的作者所写的小说，如詹姆斯·查特尼和乔斯林·赫尔希-格斯特。我想我们确实公正地对待了奥利维亚·海托普的《午夜的表弟》和E·托马斯·华洛普那部尖锐的历史剧《棍子的商业目的》。
As I said, often these miniseries are based upon works of fiction. But just as frequently, we find equally-compelling material simply by opening our daily newspapers, contacting the survivors or perpetrators, and buying their stories, which are then adapted by any number of our skilled writers. This was the case with The Boiling of Sister Catherine , a tragic event which I think we explored with a great deal of dignity.
如我所说，迷你剧通常基于虚构作品。但同样频繁地，我们只需打开日报，联系幸存者或肇事者，购买他们的故事，然后由我们许多熟练的编剧改编，就能找到同样引人入胜的材料。《凯瑟琳修女的沸煮》就是这种情况，这是一个我想我们以极大的尊严探索的悲剧性事件。
We recently aired another heartbreaking true-life drama, this one based upon a single mother forced to drown her own children, driving them into a lake in a desperate attempt to hold onto her new, handsome boyfriend. Sunroof Optional touched a lot of nerves. And I was proud to be part of it.
我们最近播出了另一个令人心碎的真实生活剧，这个是基于一位被迫溺死自己孩子、把他们赶进湖里，只为绝望地抓住她新的英俊男友的单身母亲。 《天窗可选》触动了很多人的神经。我很自豪能成为其中的一员。
Well, the miniseries based upon novels generate a good deal of interest. It's these real-life dramas that tend to draw a larger audience. Why? I chalk it up to five simple words we use in every print or televised promotion. Five words. Based upon a true story. Not made up in the mind of some typist but true.
好吧，基于小说的迷你剧引起了很大兴趣。但正是这些真实生活的剧作往往能吸引更大的观众群。为什么？我归结为我们在每个印刷或电视宣传中使用的五个简单的词。五个词。根据真实故事改编。不是某个打字员脑子里编出来的，而是真实的。
There also happens to be a fair amount of money in it for the savvy criminals or unfortunate victim who wants to turn his or her grief into something with a little more buying power than the tear-stained pillow. Yes, Mr. Timothy, that's all very interesting, but what does it have to do with Christmas, and where the H-E- double toothpicks is Brother Phil Hickey? Well, I'm getting to that.
对于那些想要把自己的悲伤变成比泪流满面的枕头更有购买力的东西的聪明罪犯或不幸受害者来说，这里面也有相当多的钱。是的，蒂莫西先生，这很有趣，但这和圣诞节有什么关系？菲尔·希基兄弟在哪里？好吧，我正要谈到这一点。
As I've explained, we've got our dramas and our miniseries. And then, ever mindful of the calendar, we've also got our holiday specials. You've no doubt seen or heard of them. Vince Flatwood's Christmas in Cambodia or Christmas Rappin' with Extraneous BVD and the Skeleton Crew . I could go on and on.
正如我解释的，我们有我们的剧作和迷你剧。然后，时刻不忘日历，我们还有我们的节日特别节目。你们无疑看到或听说过它们。文斯·弗拉特伍德的《柬埔寨圣诞》或《带有外部BVD和骷髅船员的圣诞说唱》。我还可以没完没了地说下去。
But every now and then-- and it's rare-- once every blue moon, we come upon a marriage of the true-life miniseries and the holiday special. And that is what we in the television industry like to call art. Our viewers saw art last Easter with a two-part Somebody's on My Cross . And they saw it again in A Wishbone for Little Sleepy , in which a hardened gang member carjacks two Dutch tourists so that he can spend Thanksgiving on his grandfather's turkey farm. Oh, these programs both won Emmy awards on the basis of their hard-hitting portrayal of a typical American life.
但偶尔——这种情况很少——每隔几个月，我们就会遇到真实生活迷你剧和节日特别节目的联姻。这就是我们在电视行业喜欢称之为艺术的东西。我们的观众去年复活节看到了艺术，那部两部分的《有人在我的十字架上》。他们又在《给小睡的一根愿望骨》中看到了它，在那部片子里，一个顽固的黑帮成员抢劫了两名荷兰游客，以便能在他祖父的火鸡农场过感恩节。哦，这两个节目都因为对典型美国生活的强有力描述而赢得了艾美奖。
This creature we call art is just as special as the day we call Christmas. And you people wouldn't be sitting here if you didn't agree with me. I'm standing before you, the congregation of this simple, shack-like Pentecostal church, because I care. I care about all of us.
我们称之为艺术的这个东西，就像我们称之为圣诞节的那一天一样特别。如果你们不同意我的观点，你们就不会坐在这里。我站在你们面前，这个简单的、棚屋一样的五旬节派教堂的会众，是因为我在乎。我在乎我们所有人。
Now, I'm not stupid, and I won't pretend to be. I read the papers and magazines and know full well that one of your members is somewhat famous. She gave unto her only son a very special Christmas gift. I'm sure you know what I'm talking about. A court order prevents me from saying her name, but you know who she is. She's seated right now in this very room. Oh, she drew quite a bit of attention one year ago today when she presented her child with the greatest gift a person can give, the gift of life.
现在，我不傻，我也不会假装自己傻。我读报纸和杂志，很清楚你们的一名成员很有名。她给了她唯一的儿子一份非常特别的圣诞礼物。我相信你们知道我在说什么。法院命令禁止我说出她的名字，但你们知道她是谁。她现在就坐在这个房间里。哦，一年前的今天，当她给她的孩子提供了一个人能给予的最伟大的礼物——生命的礼物时，她吸引了相当多的关注。
Being local people, you're no doubt familiar with the story, but please allow me to recount it in my own way, because I like the sound of it. Call me crazy, but this does something to me. One year ago, on a frosty Christmas morning, a young, widowed mother, poor as dirt but still attractive in her own way, took drastic measures in order to save the life of a five-year-old child who was dying of kidney failure.
作为本地人，你们无疑熟悉这个故事，但请允许我用我自己的方式重述它，因为我喜欢它的声音。说我疯了吧，但这确实对我有些影响。一年前，在一个寒冷的圣诞早晨，一位年轻的寡妇母亲，穷得像土一样，但仍以她自己的方式有吸引力，为了挽救一个患有肾衰竭、濒临死亡的五岁孩子，采取了极端的措施。
She had no health insurance or dialysis machine. But she did have a heavy Bible which she used to whack the boy against the back of his head, knocking him out in order to spare him from the pain that would follow. Taking a rusty pen knife and a simple, dime-store sewing kit, the young woman proceeded to remove one of her kidneys and successfully transplant the vital organ in her son's vulnerable body.
她没有健康保险或透析机。但她确实有一本沉重的圣经，她用它敲打男孩的后脑勺，把他打晕，为了让他免受随后的痛苦。用一把生锈的小折刀和一个简单的、杂货店缝纫工具包，这位年轻女性切除了自己的一个肾脏，并成功地将这个重要器官移植到她儿子脆弱的身体里。
She did this with no prior experience, completely ignorant of even the simplest of medical procedures. The child had a different blood type. And the kidney was much too large for his small, vulnerable body. But still, the organ took, defying all laws of science. This operation was performed not in a sterile surgical environment but in a dark and dingy hay-filled barn, not unlike a manger.
她在没有任何先验经验的情况下做到了这一点，对即使是最简单的医疗程序也完全无知。孩子的血型不同。而肾脏对他的小而脆弱的身体来说太大了。但器官还是存活了，违背了所有的科学规律。这次手术不是在无菌的手术环境中进行的，而是在一个黑暗、肮脏、充满干草的谷仓里，和一个马槽没什么两样。
There was manure in that barn. There were spiders and fleas. But still, the transplant was a success. The boy awoke, and shortly afterwards, was noticed happily playing in the bramble-filled ditch which constituted his front yard. When asked how she managed to perform such complex and delicate surgery, the ignorant young woman said only, "I done it with the help of the Lord."
那谷仓里有粪便。有蜘蛛和跳蚤。但移植还是成功了。男孩醒了过来，不久之后，被发现快乐地在他前院那条布满荆棘的沟里玩耍。当被问及她是如何设法进行如此复杂和精细的手术时，那位无知的年轻女性只说：“我是靠主的帮助做到的。”
Now, either she's the biggest liar since my third wife, or a miracle took place in that squalid, tin-roof barn. A miracle witnessed by only two goats, half a dozen chickens, and a game cock with a broken leg. And unfortunately, these animals, like the young woman herself, are refusing to talk. Reporters crawled out of the woodwork, nosing around for answers. But still, she held her tongue.
现在，要么她是自我的第三任妻子以来最大的骗子，要么奇迹发生在那个肮脏、铁皮屋顶的谷仓里。一个只有两只山羊、半打鸡和一只断腿斗鸡见证的奇迹。遗憾的是，这些动物和那个年轻女性自己一样，拒绝说话。记者们从木制品里爬出来，到处寻找答案。但她仍然守口如瓶。
Let me point out that there are quite a few perplexing questions involving this incident. For example, isn't it funny how this poverty-stricken young widow could have an attorney but not a washing machine? That's right. She's being counseled by her brother, who just barely managed to pass the state bar exam after attending some fourth-rate state college. The man is a loser but calls himself a lawyer. Go figure. Her brother is a public defender, a man who chooses to spend his life representing thieves and rapists. Here's a guy who sits down and shares his sandwich with the scum of the earth. And he's advising this young woman on how to lead her life?
让我指出，这个事件涉及不少令人困惑的问题。例如，这个贫困的年轻寡妇怎么会有一个律师却没有洗衣机，这难道不滑稽吗？没错。她正由她的兄弟提供咨询，那个在读完某个四流州立大学后勉强通过州律师考试的人。那个人是个失败者，却自称是律师。去想吧。她的兄弟是一位公职辩护人，一个选择终身代表小偷和强奸犯的人。这是一个坐下来与世间渣滓分享三明治的家伙。而他却在建议这位年轻女性如何过她的生活？
This young woman's brother has foolishly respected his client's desire to turn down all offers in regard to her story. Even worse, he's placed a restraining order against the very people who are helping to bring this story out from the shadows and into the light. I can understand turning away the book and motion picture people, but this is TV we're talking about.
这个年轻女性的兄弟愚蠢地尊重了他客户拒绝所有关于她故事的出价的愿望。更糟糕的是，他发布了针对那些正在帮助把这个故事从阴影带入光明的正是那些人的限制令。我可以理解拒绝图书和电影界的人，但我们说的是电视。
The fact of the matter is, until this young woman agrees to sit down and reason with us, we have no story. Because without her cooperation, there's no way of knowing what really took place in that god-forsaken barn on the morning of Christmas one year ago today. And it's a tragedy that her son is no longer available to fill in those missing pieces. Here, this woman sacrificed one of her own kidneys in order to save the boy's life. And six days later, he was struck down by a remote-location TV news truck.
事实是，除非这位年轻女性同意坐下来和我们讲道理，否则我们没有故事。因为没有她的合作，就无法知道一年前的圣诞节早晨在那个被上帝遗忘的谷仓里到底发生了什么。悲剧的是，她的儿子不再能够填补那些缺失的片段了。在这里，这个女人为了挽救男孩的生命牺牲了自己的一颗肾脏。而六天后，他被一辆远程电视新闻卡车撞倒了。
Unlike certain other people, I respected her grief and kept my distance for the better part of a week, allowing this woman, in her own private way, to come to terms with her terrible irony. Speaking through her brother, the young woman declined to initiate a lawsuit or even press charges. It's been rumored that she's motivated by her deeply-held religious beliefs. And that is why, on this Christmas morning, I'm turning to you, her fellow parishioners. Let me just lay my cards on the table and give it to you straight. You are poor people, but you don't deserve to be.
与某些其他人不同，我尊重她的悲伤，并保持了一周左右的距离，让这个女人以她自己的私人方式来接受这令人恐惧的讽刺。通过她的兄弟，那位年轻女性拒绝发起诉讼，甚至没有报案。有传言说，她的动机是她根深蒂固的宗教信仰。这就是为什么，在这个圣诞早晨，我转向你们，她的同教区居民。让我把牌摊在桌面上，直接告诉你们。你们是穷人，但你们不应该如此。
I've spent some time in this area and seen your pathetic, ramshackle houses resembling so many piles of firewood. These are places I wouldn't use to store a lawnmower, let alone raise a family. People in our inner-city ghettos are riding around in brand-new Jeeps, yet you walk to church every Sunday lucky just to have shoes on your feet. But it doesn't have to be that way. Here it is, Christmas Day. And your children probably woke up to a knee sock full of twice-chewed gum and a doll made out of used Band-Aids.
我在这个地区待过一段时间，看到你们那些可怜的、破烂的房子，就像一堆柴火。这些是我甚至不会用来存割草机的地方，更不用说抚养一个家庭了。我们内城贫民窟的人们开着全新的吉普车，而你们每个星期天步行去教堂，能有鞋穿就算幸运了。但不一定要那样。现在是圣诞节了。你们的孩子可能是在一双装满被嚼过两次的口香糖和用旧创可贴做的玩偶的短袜中醒来的。
I'm not putting down handmade gifts. But don't they deserve something better than what you can currently afford to give them? Ladies and gentlemen, this is one year when Santa is definitely coming to town. The question is, do you welcome him with open arms or turn away, much like a certain young woman and her devious brother, to whom money means nothing?
我不是在贬低手工礼物。但他们不应该得到比你们目前负担得起的更好的东西吗？女士们，先生们，今年圣诞老人一定会进城。问题是，你们是张开双臂欢迎他，还是转过身去，就像那个拒绝金钱对她毫无意义的年轻女性和她狡猾的兄弟一样？
You know, flying in early this morning, I thought I might offer each of you a brand new car and $1,000 in cash. Now though, looking out over your kind, sallow faces, I'm thinking of upping that to a brand-new car, factory-fresh side-by-side refrigerator and freezer, and $1,200 in cash. Sound good?
你们知道，今天清晨飞过来时，我想我可能每人送你们一辆新车和1000美元现金。现在呢，看着你们善良、蜡黄的脸，我在考虑把奖励提高到一辆全新的车、出厂价的并排式冰箱和冷冻柜，以及1200美元现金。听起来不错吗？
That's what I promise to give each and every one of you if you can convince this young woman to help me tell her story. Apparently the finer things in life mean nothing to her. So be it. But is it fair for her to force you, her friends and neighbors, to suffer the same lifestyle? By refusing to sign my contract and spend an afternoon recounting the facts to me and my top-notch writers, this young woman is ensuring that none of you will ever experience the pleasures that most people-- civilized people-- take for granted. She'll be saying, fine. Let their babies die of malnutrition and staph infection. She lost her son the hard way, and maybe in her mind, you should too. Is this the Christmas your holiday dreams come true, or is it the day you discover just how petty and spiteful one person can truly be?
如果你们能说服这个年轻女性帮助我讲述她的故事，我保证给你们每个人这些。显然，生活中的美好事物对她毫无意义。那就这样吧。但她强迫你们，她的朋友和邻居，遭受同样的生活方式公平吗？通过拒绝签署我的合同并花一个下午向我和我顶尖的编剧讲述事实，这个年轻女性正在确保你们永远无法体验大多数人——文明人——认为理所当然的快乐。她会说，很好。让他们的婴儿死于营养不良和葡萄球菌感染吧。她以艰难的方式失去了儿子，也许在她的脑海里，你们也应该如此。这是你们节日梦想成真的圣诞节，还是你们发现一个人竟然能如此琐碎和恶毒的日子？
If, like her, you're not interested in money, cars and appliances, you could convince her to sign the contract anyway, and then donate your rewards to charity. You'd have a pretty hard time finding people less fortunate than yourselves, but if that's your bag, I'd more than respect it.
如果像她一样，你们对金钱、汽车和电器不感兴趣，你们仍然可以说服她签署合同，然后把你们的奖励捐给慈善机构。你们很难找到比自己更不幸的人，但如果那是你们的兴趣，我会非常尊重。
Giving is what the holiday season is all about. I'm just wondering how easy will it be to sleep tonight with your threadbare blankets and Christian ethics, knowing that somewhere outside your plastic-paned window, an old, crippled woman is begging for coins in some glass-filled because you were too wrapped up in yourself to give her a side-by-side refrigerator freezer. Because let me tell you something, not giving is no different than taking.
给予就是节日季节的全部意义所在。我只是想知道，今晚睡在破旧的毯子和基督教道德中会有多容易，因为你们知道，在你们塑料窗外某处，一个老迈、残疾的女人正乞求硬币，因为你们太沉浸在自己世界里，而不愿意给她一个并排式冰箱冷冻柜。因为让我告诉你们，不给予和夺取没有任何区别。
I was going to leave you with that thought, but as long as I'm here, let me add a little something else. Even if you refuse to reason with this young woman, I will still produce my holiday special. This, though, will be my story, requiring the help of no one. it will be about a small group of so-called evangelical Christians so busy rolling on the floor and beating tambourines that they forgot what Christmas really stands for. It won't have an uplifting seasonal message and very well may send 20 million children off to bed thinking that perhaps this God person isn't everything he's cracked up to be, that maybe they're celebrating the birthday of a con artist no different than the stick figures worshipped by the Pygmies or the Muslims.
我本来想给你们留下这个想法，但既然我在这儿，让我补充一点别的。即使你们拒绝与这个年轻女性讲道理，我也仍然会制作我的节日特别节目。然而，这将是我的故事，不需要任何人的帮助。它将讲述一群所谓的福音派基督徒的故事，他们太忙于在地板上翻滚和拍打手鼓，以至于忘记了圣诞节真正代表什么。它不会有令人振奋的季节性信息，而且很有可能送两千万儿童去睡觉，让他们认为也许上帝这个人并不像传说中那样，也许他们正在庆祝一个和俾格米人或穆斯林崇拜的棒状人物没什么区别的骗子的生日。
I'd prefer to do a more compelling story of your young friend, but that, ladies and gentlemen, is up to you. Do the catering trucks roll into town next week loaded down with cola and mouth-watering pasta salad, free of charge to any shabbily-dressed church member who wants to earn good money as an extra? Or do we film an uglier version of this story on some faraway sound stage. One year from today, will you be seated on a nice, new sofa, watching as this young woman's heart-wrenching miracle is brought to life on your wide-screen TV? Or will you be picking the thorns out from between your toes and wondering where you went wrong?
我宁愿做一个关于你们年轻朋友的更引人入胜的故事，但那，女士们，先生们，取决于你们。餐饮车下周会载满可乐和令人垂涎的意面沙拉进城吗，对任何想要作为临时演员赚点钱的衣着寒酸的教会成员免费提供？还是我们在某个遥远的声场拍摄这个故事的更丑陋版本。从今天起的一年后，你们会坐在漂亮的新沙发上，看着这个年轻女性令人心碎的奇迹在你们的宽屏电视上实现吗？还是你们会从脚趾间挑出刺，纳闷自己哪里做错了？
All I'm asking for is a few details. There are little things, details, but they can make all the difference in the world when it comes to fulfilling a dream. Maybe while you're thinking, you can entertain a few detailed dreams of your own. I want you to imagine yourself leaning back against the warm, fragrant upholstery of a brand-new automobile. Your healthy children are still fighting over who got to ride in the front seat, but you don't allow that to bother you. In time, they'll return their attention to the bounty of toys lying at their feet.
我所要求的只是一些细节。那是小事，细节，但当谈到实现梦想时，它们可以带来天壤之别。也许当你们在思考时，你们可以娱乐一下你们自己的一些详细梦想。我想要你们想象自己靠在全新汽车温暖、芬芳的内饰上。你们健康的孩子们还在争论谁能坐在前座，但你们不让这困扰你们。迟早，他们会把注意力回到脚边那一大堆玩具上。
Back at the house, the ice cubes are eagerly awaiting the kiss of a finely aged bourbon. And there's still enough money in your wallet to make your neighbors jealous. It's Christmas Day, and all is right with the world.
回到房子里，冰块正急切地等待着精制波本威士忌的亲吻。钱包里还有足够的钱让你们的邻居嫉妒。这是圣诞节，世界一切正常。
Matt Malloy.
马特·马洛伊。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder, Jennifer Ferro, and myself, with Nancy Updike and Alix Spiegel, senior editor Paul Tough, contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Howard and Alex Blumberg. Working sound and lights and stage here at the Wadsworth Theatre in Los Angeles, Bob Carlson running sound [? with Keith Endo, ?] [? Jessica Wodinksy, ?] [? Eileen Cooley, ?] David [? Muller, ?] [? Anail Duwan. ?]
好吧，我们的节目今天由茱莉·斯奈德、詹妮弗·费罗和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克和阿里克斯·斯皮格尔协助，高级编辑保罗·塔夫，特约编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自雷切尔·霍华德和亚历克斯·布隆伯格。在洛杉矶沃兹沃斯剧院负责音响、灯光和舞台的是鲍勃·卡尔森运行音响[？和基思·远藤，？][？杰西卡·沃丁斯基，？][？艾琳·库利，？]大卫[？穆勒，？][？阿奈尔·杜万。？]
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you would like to buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us at WBEZ in Chicago. Phone number there, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买这个或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ。电话号码是312-832-3380。再次重复，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是[email protected]。 《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia. I'm Ira Glass. Merry Christmas. Happy Hanukkah. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责。我是艾拉·格拉斯。圣诞快乐。光明节快乐。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共电台。